[Music]
all right thank you everybody now two
Germans called Max in a row how much
better can it get um okay I'm Max um I
work with P um I am still I did am still
doing a project at D bank so some
credits go to them about transaction
monitoring where we're building an
automated solutions to classify uh fraud
and transactions
and one big part of this was looking
into explainable ey to try to understand
our model and really um see how we make
predictions so that's what this talk
will be about today um we're going to
have a brief look at transaction
monitoring in general uh what is even
then look at the basics of shap um have
a quick look at how to implement this in
Python and then dive into the uh
different uh graphs you can get out to
really understand your model on a global
and a local level uh finish up with uh
um yeah how we can we translate this
from something that that we understand
to a more yeah let's call it human
readable output for an analyst for
example um let's get started transaction
monitoring well we all know it um we're
human beings we have phones we send
money to a friends business whatsoever
online shopping Black Friday in practice
of course money goes to an intermediary
your bank um and gets sent through um
yeah many peoples do it and of course
there are some Black Sheep involved so
that means uh by law from the Dutch
National Bank every bank is obliged to
monitor every single transaction for
terrorism financing and for money
laundering it's quite a big task um yeah
there's various systems in place that
can be from really manual inspection um
automated dual-based systems but also um
yeah now looking more and more into um
AI systems um yeah monitoring is
required the uh Dutch national bank has
their own thoughts about AI solution
ions they're a bit more conservative
than VR but they're slowly warming up to
it but in any case whatever you do you
have to really um yeah monitor your
solution and be able to explain how you
come to
outcomes um yeah and this of course
where explainable I or XI comes into um
into play um yeah you might ask yourself
okay I have a model I have great output
85% accuracy what I know why should I
spend more time now on on
XI um yeah my answer would be um it can
really be used to improve your model
even further uh which maybe is not the
key thing but really um what it what it
helped us with tremendously is really to
understand our data and really yeah get
more into the depth of it to to get to
know the model how do make decisions and
how to changes in data also affect the
model
outcome um so that's already quite
important uh and you can use it in the
end to explain the model output to an
end user if you have one and lastly
maybe not the best reason but yeah it
was mentioned before the eua ACT is up
on us soon and that will likely mean
that we all have to explain our models
by by law um so yeah it's going to come
um and that means we don't have the
simple data blackbox a model output
diagram anymore but there will be
something in between and then um yeah to
sketch this a little bit now maybe the
first question you would ask yourself do
I really have to explain my output if
not well then I think the world is you
can go go all crazy and use any kind of
model you want uh looking at the
previous talk um if you do want to
explain your data you can make a
cautious choice to pick a model which is
really inherently explainable so this
would be for example something like
logistic regression K K&N or trees um
which then might be not have the
performance that you need so if you go
to something different um then you need
XI methods really um and in general I
would say there's two choices one would
be to pick something it's very specific
for your model um I don't know attention
gradient fency or you say um no let's Pi
something very general um yeah for
example um shap pation or lime and in
this case we're going to focus on on
shap that's what we picked um yeah
reason being why we picked shap is that
it's a very unified framework it can be
used for many models it's model agnostic
and we hope to scale this also into
different solutions in the bank uh it
can be used for Global and local
exibility it's by now quite widely used
and well documented so yeah stack
Overflow is your friend and um it is
relatively fast and extremely easy to
use uh before I show you how to use it
uh let's have a very quick introduction
what is it what does it actually do so
shap calculates the shap values and you
calculate a shap value for every feature
and basically the shap value is nothing
more than the model output with your
feature minus the model output without
your feature so then you you get to know
already how important is this one
feature for my model in practice if you
look at any common I don't know
classifier like XG boost yeah your
features are fixed so you can't really
remove a feature um but there's a smart
way to tackle this uh we don't really
take them out but instead we we make
them random and then such they don't
have any predictive power anymore and if
you want to do this properly you have to
do it for every feature subset and um
yeah to maybe show it a bit um imagine
you have a model with 10 features then
you could make a subset S1 where you
make the feature one and feature five
random you can make one where only the
second feature is uh is uh is random and
so on uh however if you have 10 features
you end up with, 24 subsets it gets
quite expensive computationally and
that's not even lot of features so so
what do you do well uh luckily shap
includes approximations so in the end
you can reduce this to a linear problem
and then make this um yeah into
something that you can actually use
practically every
day okay so that's we do we want to
calculate these the shap values how can
we do this in uh in Python
um I I try to make a very basic example
of how you could make such a um yeah
classifier model from beginning to end
um let's assume we want to classify
Penguins we all like those so maybe some
people like cats more we load our data
we have to Define X and Y data so data
and labels um oh yeah sorry wrong button
uh we split this into training T testing
data and quite important later on if you
have numeric and categorical features
you want to distinguish how you
pre-process them so let's write down
which ones they are and then um yeah to
train our
classifier let's uh make a a simple
pipeline so first of all we take care of
numeric features um
apply a simple imputer and a scaler the
same thing we have to do for categorical
features again imputation and in this
case you do one hot encoding we have to
combine this all somehow um for this we
can use a column Transformer and we give
this the the two um pipelines and the
feature names so then this guy knows
already what to do with which feature
column and then lastly we can make the
final pipeline trainer model uh fit the
training testing data and we have a x
boost train model okay nice um we have a
train model now let's um get actually
calculating chap values uh before we can
do it we have to get our model out of
the pipeline because we need really the
trained model and um if you have the
model itself and you would use it in
chap you would get graphs of very
obscure feature names because the model
itself doesn't know what a feature is
called you would have have a graph of
feature one to feature 10 uh would be
quite hard to find out which feature has
in in importance uh in the end so we uh
we make a list uh it's really just a
list of all feature names there's a few
more lines because we have to collect
all the one hot encod features um we
update our
model up um to set the feature names in
the model and then um as the last step
for pre-processing and now we're almost
there let's apply this pation uh
pipeline that we created before on our
data that we have the right scaling in
our data and now we have all we need we
have a a train model with feature names
we have data and right format and we can
throw this into the uh the shap uh
explainer and it's only two lines that's
the nice thing it's very easy um first
it's an XG boost model so we picked the
Tre explainer from shap then we have it
and the next step is only to tell it
okay go ahead calculate the shap values
and um I think the the only really
important things to consider if if you
want to do it is one um yeah watch out
for categorical features uh if they were
not encoded and um secondly that you
work with rescaled numerical features so
later on if you look at your your graphs
to uh to keep this in mind okay now we
have uh all the shap values for the
features what can we learn I think now
it really uh we can dive into our model
and the first thing we're going to look
at is global explainability so really
understand um what does the model do as
a whole uh which features are
responsible for model predictions and
also how to changes and features change
the model output and then um on the
right hand side you see a graph with all
the features there's some combo feature
then maybe we know for a customer is he
a warlord the drug dealer uh braans are
quite famous for drug dealing and moneya
laundering so it's important to monitor
um but what you see in the end is the
the shap value for the first feature
this com feature is huge compared to
anything else um so basically any
decision made by the model will be made
depending on this one single feature and
what we actually saw during model
training we had a model with 100%
accuracy so we had already yeah all the
alarm bells ringing uh looking at this
also became clear why that this one
feature makes all the predictions and
when we um yeah narrow narrowed it down
to the feature we had to look at it and
notice we actually have data leakage
from the labels into the feature and we
had to then uh yeah refactor or take out
this feature and then retrain the model
uh so we did that um this guy went away
we retrained the model rren app and we
got to something like this which looks a
bit more sensible um yeah still some
things to learn uh first of all if
someone is a warlord the shap Val is
very high so that's apparently a good
indication if someone is or is not a
money launder still the strongest
feature yeah then you could again check
does it make sense is my data good is
something wrong should I refactor the
feature um that's really up to you as a
data scientist working with the the data
owners and secondly if we look at the
the last two features if someone owns a
y or has um one or multiple house in
Luxembourg apparently this has almost no
contribution to the model output um and
then you can use this to to really yeah
decide for example do we want to keep
these features you could kick them out
of your model retrain it evaluate the
performance and then possibly make your
model simpler which at least for us
having a model in production is uh is
quite important to have the the simplest
possible
model uh okay now we know kind of what
is important but we don't really know
like in which way does it push it to to
making positive negative predictions and
that's what we can use the um feature
sensitivity plot for um let's first have
a good look of what it tells us so we
have colors here on the right uh they
tell us if a feature has a high or a low
value and then on the x-axis we see
whether the prediction pushes the model
to a positive or to a negative
prediction so for example looking at the
first feature um if someone is a warlord
it pushes the model to a high shap value
meaning a POS prediction so likely a
money launder if someone is not a
warlord blue color um likely he is not a
money
launder um you can also see for the the
warlord feature yeah it's quite nicely
separated there's a big
gap and um you can make a clear
distinction um yeah depending on the
feature one thing that we uh learned
which surprised us if you look at the
owns yard feature you can see that if
someone owns a yard so red color uh it's
actually more likely that he's not a
money launder because it pushes the
model towards the uh the left um and if
he does own a yak he is uh if he does
not own a yak he's more likely to be a
money launderer so it's kind of uh yeah
against the the initial thoughts we had
from the data and the discussion with
with data experts
um which let us in the end to defect to
uh to remove this feature um until we
understand that the data better and uh
and can make more more sense of
it then I want to show you one more plot
for a global
explainability namely the uh decision
plot um yeah decision plot is also it's
maybe a bit more tricky to follow um
what you see here is individual lines
each line is one thing single
prediction um the x-axis at the bottom
shows you the model output in reality
there would be more features and you see
a convergence at some point to the
average model output which would be it's
binary classifier so
0.5 um the y- AIS are the featurs
they're ordered in um yeah from top to
bottom descending important so the most
important ones at the top and then if
you follow a line a thinging prediction
then at each feature the the chap value
from this specific features added and
you arrive at the end at the top at the
final model output so what you can do um
is you can follow either a single lines
or a group of lines to understand how
how features influence this group of
predictions um so for example if we take
this strain here we can see that the uh
the final feature the war warlord one
pushes them all far to the uh to the
right
and how can you use it um yeah for
example you could um pick a few false
predictions um that you want to gain
more insights and then you can find out
if there's like a common feature driving
them all into a certain direction of the
defin and model
output um okay now we kind of understand
um what happens on a global scale but
you can also use shap to look at the LC
cck
explainability and um this can really
tell us how did the model come to a very
specific uh outcome and um what are the
the contributions of individual features
for the specific outcome and in uh in
chap there are three uh plots available
for this there's the local bar plot the
waterfall plot and the force plot uh
they all tell more or less the same
information but then in a in a yeah
somewhat different
representation uh let's start with the
local bar plot uh it's quite similar to
the the GL Global power plot um you can
see basically um each feature is really
off of one single prediction so you can
also see the the value of the single
prediction that the feature had um so
you can learn in this case you would sum
it up you see it's a a nonmon laundary
case because the uh the um uh shap
values on the left side they Dominate
and you can see which features would be
dominant for the single prediction um
personally yeah I prefer the the next
plot because I think it's more
insightful
um which would be the the waterfall plot
again it's more or less the same but
then what you see is that you start at
the um bottom at the x-axis you start at
your base output so again 0.5 in terms
of probability and you added feature by
feature the shap values till you come up
at the the final model output for this
um for this case um what can you learn
yeah this case was certainly a nonmon
Laing case because you have a negative
output of your model um the customer is
a warlord um and this canceled out the
fact that he's a drug dealer and he had
a previous alert yeah then looking at um
at it from a a data perspective the
question would be okay does this feature
make sense especially the top one um
because from a analyst perspective um
yeah we found out that if he's a drug
dealer and he was flaged before it's
actually quite a strong indication so
probably this is a uh false negative and
should be flagged differently so you can
use this to really um understand your
data understand your model and see how
you came to to predictions and use also
for for in-depth discussion with your
your analyst in our case for
example um and then the last plot um
looking at Global uh sorry at local
explainability is the force plot uh the
force plot uh shows again for a single
prediction the the uh outcome but then
in an um additive Force layout so you
can see all positive shap values on one
side uh all negative ones on the right
side yeah in this case uh this person
liked online shopping um most the
dominant fact that it was a money
laundering case and um yeah it was again
not a money laundering case because he
wasn't a warlord um he didn't live in
brand um and he was also not an
influencer so I mean that's very strong
medication and yeah obviously and if you
haven't noticed these are of course not
real real features that we would use in
a bank but um yeah I had to to censor
what we actually use because it's uh
yeah somewhat of a business secret to
not allow you to ccent the the rules we
have set
up um okay now looking back um I think
by now we can say okay like on a global
level how did we come to decision on a
local level we can dive into single
predictions to understand how we make
decisions um uses for example um for
yeah false frictions to understand where
it's going wrong but if I didn't lose
yet and you look like this um you would
have certainly used lost your model end
user um in my opinion chap is really a
great tool but it's really a tool for
data scientist it's for us it's not for
a for a novice um and to to explain the
model to the end user we need something
uh somewhat different uh in our case we
yeah there's really an an analyst a
person somewhere he gets a model output
he has to use this in his um evaluation
and only a a score or rating is not
enough so he really has to know why did
this model come to a certain
prediction um we are somewhat limited um
what we can provide them it's it's not
there's no powerbi there's no fancy um
yeah web dashboard uh it's Lally just
create some Excel or text files that
they they get um so we had to work with
this to try to make a translation from
from shap values to something that they
could use in their actual daily
work and um our solution was quite uh
quite simple um what we did in the end
is we um create a dictionary or actually
two uh where we had just a textual
explanation of each feature that we have
and we do this for high and and low
values so the high one being if you are
a or if it is a mon laundering case we
pick the the top dictionary if it is not
a mon laundering case we pick the the
low
dictionary um Second Step um let's look
at a single transaction um what was it
let's assume it is a monol laundering
case step three for the specific case we
find the top three features um but not
absolute but really specifically the the
top drivers for this position uh that is
a money laundering case and four step um
yeah simply get the um the predicted
outcome of the model for the single case
and then we can put this all together
and this is basically um what we also in
the end supplied to the the end user of
our model so he just gets nice output
saying hey look guy um we're quite sure
quite convinced it's a monol laundering
case um with a certain probability of
75% um reason being he's a warlord uh
he's a drug dealer and an influencer
can't get much better than that um and
then that's something that they can work
with and and also validate their data
and check if it actually all makes sense
and yeah I think here it looks a bit
simple and stupid um in practice our
feature names they're yeah a lot more
complex there's combination of of
different data source to makeup features
they a lot more obscure so if you would
simply give them like a feature name and
a value for them it would simply not be
sufficient so we had to make this kind
of like a translation step in
between um now uh to already sum up
slowly
um yeah for me the the main takeaway is
that um yeah shap is only one tool I
mentioned in the beginning there's uh
there are more tools out there um shap
might not fit your problem but if you
want to start somewhere it's quite a
good start you can use it even for an
llm um for that matter to to understand
how the next predictions are made um but
also maybe keep in mind yeah it doesn't
replace other tools so if if you look
for example at a correlation Matrix like
the the most basic um data analysis
tasks uh you should still stick to those
and really see this as an additional
tool in your toolbox to extend your your
knowledge and your depth of insight that
you can gain from your
data um secondly yeah I hope I could
show you a bit um what is global feature
importance yeah just keep in mind like
about the yeah global view on your model
how does it come to decisions um how do
specific changes and features affect
your model but you can also use it for
local feature importance so really
understanding a singular prediction uh
including all your data of how this
decision was formed and uh and made and
um yeah maybe the most important Point
um yeah V started out of this really
because it was a requirement for us we
we had to be explainable for um for
compliancy but in the end we actually
yeah kind of fell in love with love of
it and really glad we used it it really
gave us tremendous insights really we
understood our data better we had a a
great tool to communicate with um the
model user in the end um and now have
much tighter collaboration because it's
yeah kind of a a platform that helps us
communicate and and speak in the same
language um so yeah I think there's many
reasons to use it um I would encourage
everyone uh to add it to their toolbox
if you haven't done so
already um yeah with this I want to uh
thank you um for listening to me and and
um I think there's some time left for
questions and in case there shouldn't be
enough time then I'm around here or you
can also contact me via phone and email
and uh I'm happy to uh to elaborate
further thank
you we do have time for questions
so okay I think the person in the
back I
f
um how do you do it for a multiclass
data yeah the same basically yeah so the
shap does support a multiclass um uh you
can uh actually the example if the
Penguins would have been a multiclass
model I can also make this available on
on GitHub if anyone wants to download it
it's open source data uh only your plots
get slightly more complicated because
you have um yeah a multiclass problem
but it's same the same methodology how
is it uh the same do you do one vs rest
or I one versus the rest for all of the
classes or is the difference um no you
you get um I only looked at it very
briefly but um you would have then uh
different for example barp different
color colored bars depending on the
predicted class to tell you how much the
uh the feature influence or the feature
drives a certain class
prediction think there were two people
in the front can you
pass
all right um thanks for the talk maybe a
bit more uh a question bit more on the
technical side but um to me it seems
like calculating a shap ratio is highly
dependent on the actual inference that
you choose for the model right so um you
choose an inference you put that through
the model and then you vary the the
features and you look what the impact is
on the actual prediction right so the
selection of the of the data that you
use to inference seems very important to
me and um I'd like your thoughts on the
following scenario so what happens if
you do you calculate shap values as a
mean and if so what happens if you have
a um an activation a feature that is low
probability but high impact because in
the mean it wouldn't show up as a big
impact but it would be very important
for certain scenarios so so do you deal
with those types of questions at all uh
to be honest I didn't deal with it
specifically for this project um yeah I
think it's maybe a general problem if
you look at model training because if
you have um yeah low low um occurrence
with high impact yeah your model is not
I don't know to say used to it um so the
question general of how much will your
model learn if you don't have sufficient
data available um well well what I mean
is it has learned it has learned
something yeah in a specific context
that it's very important right but only
in that specific
context it's a good question yeah yeah I
don't have a very very good answer
unfortunately I think it's certainly
something to to look into I didn't it's
not something that we we encountered um
but yeah if you well my my tip would be
if you have this data and you know it
beforehand then it sounds like you have
some quite some deepain knowledge ready
and then it would be something that I
would yeah specifically look out in the
shap vales also to see if you can can
see this being really reflected in it
and and and do you calculate shap values
by by calculating a mean over different
like inferences or do you look at
individual um yeah so you can you can C
them for individual predictions in the
end yeah so you do it um for all feature
subsets for all D you can obviously you
have local importance right so you can
really calculate for a single singular
um prediction you can calculate your sh
Val you use and then if you would have
there maybe a a single prediction with a
very high there's a Fe where the model
knows it has high predictive power then
on the global level I think it would be
probably now think about it on the
global level I think it would be
averaged out possibly but then if you
look at a singular prediction where the
model also comes to the conclusion that
this feature is important then um you
you should be able to see it uh
reflected in the local plots right so
then you could use the local plots and
kind of plot the you know the
distributions over the features could
could also be a check so like a sanity
check right because you you that's what
you want basically right's let's assume
you have this feature you know it's um I
don't know the whatever a number of
chairs in your house yeah super
important uh and you know this is very
predictive but it doesn't happen many of
very often that the feature occurs um
you could then probably check on a on a
loc level where this feature does have
for example positive value if it
actually drives the model strongly in
this direction where you would expect it
to or not so it's it's important to keep
that in mind I guess when when using the
global shap values because it could fit
silently I think it could just like like
smoo it out basically yeah indeed thank
you for your so I think it's yeah it's
maybe just one one follow comment really
important to to use a tool to really
dive into your data and try to
understand and see what's happening um
and there are yeah I think edge cases if
you know them it's something to really
consider um but then also yeah where
your model makes right choices maybe not
even the the most important mode it's
most interesting thing to look at but
look at like um where where does it go
wrong false positive false negatives um
what drives these um yeah are there like
like clusters where like one feature
like this is W example it's just
dominating anything else so even if all
the the flags would Point towards money
laundering yeah if this guy is negative
you will still that still end up with a
non money laundering case which is not
what you want and then how do you you
counteract them would you have to do
your model weights for example or this
this feature weight yeah well thank you
for the awesome answer yeah can you pass
it the back oh
boy maybe in stages but we'll
see nice
nice uh yeah thanks for the presentation
I actually wanted to ask uh were you
forced to not use certain Advanced
neuron networks because of shap not
being applied to those so
um not directly no no uh so let's face
like this anything is allowed uh as long
as you can explain it that's I think how
I would I would phrase it um yeah we we
did experiment also with um different
types um so yeah just logistic
regression which was worse performance
so it was out um yeah XG boost is semi
explainable but sha to the rescue um we
we didn't try anything much more fancy
because performance was already good
enough so we we literally stopped there
um but there was no no fixed restriction
saying this is like the the most
advanced you can go I think at least for
us as long as we could explain it uh
satisfactory whatever that means then
for you um we were good to use also
other types of models
yeah great
thanks uh any more questions yeah can
you pass it to the front
again
oops uh so thank you for the talk uh I
have a question whether this is just a
illusion of explainability because at
the end of the day you don't know why
you have such sh values as you do yeah
it's just like you know which uh
features drive your model but you don't
know why you don't know why they those
features and not different ones yeah um
good question um illusion yeah you well
maybe it's good to look at it this way
that you can understand how your model
came to prediction right and you can
understand which feature has an INF
influence on it um yeah if that answers
your why question I'm not sure judging
by the question maybe not um so maybe
then you have to go either deeper or
pick really a inherently explainable
model to answer these questions um yeah
looking at like I mean you could use
this like I said for an LM uh to
understand
um the the importance of of uh I don't
know some next next five predictions so
you would get an understanding or
feeling
of maybe with which weight or importance
is choice made but certainly not the why
right because that's too far buried down
and too too abstract I think for us to
comprehend for an inherently
unexplainable model we can just get like
bri brief uh explainability semi-
explainability yeah let's say I would
say like this is like the level that you
you stay at so you you can understand of
of the the importance of the data and
the influence and of your features and
how they drive your model towards
predictions and I would say typically
that's enough um
I can imagine the case where if you
really want to develop your your own
deep neural network and then something
goes wrong you maybe want to really dive
super deeply into it understand okay why
why does it not recognize this it should
be obvious maybe for us as human is but
not for the model um but then I would
say this is not the technique that you
you have to go for then maybe you need
something a lot more model specific um
to to to understand these like more
fundamental questions and then a
followup for that which level of
explainability is uh required by the EU
low that depends on your model very good
question um so also the EU Act is not
yet in place and I'm not an expert but
from my uh at the moment Layman
understanding there will be a different
categorization of model type depending
on the risk that the model will pose and
depending on that there will be an exp
an requirement for explainability but uh
the eui is eua I was written in a very
abstract language uh so there's a lot of
room for
interpretability uh um yeah it depends
on the domain you work in for for us
what it would literally mean as as a
bank is that we have to consult also
with legal experts and then um yeah with
Dutch national bank with the all the
other Banks we would probably
collaborate to kind of um yeah work out
these more practical standards of
implementing the eua but it doesn't say
oh if you do uh uh XG boost in a bank
you have to use shap at the least that's
no no no no it's like very yeah no not
ch
but more abstract and and more unclear
at the moment yeah thank you uh so sorry
that was the last question I would love
to ask more questions from Max but uh we
have uh less time for the next talk so I
would like to Thanks Max again for the
presentation and coming here and huge
round of applause for
[Applause]
[Music]
Max